on the same show I've been single for
quite a time now same show okay how long
have you been single few years now how
many two three not probably like four or
five yeah entanglements in between that
but single for the most part
the Jada smithline
why have you been single
um I don't know life's just been real
busy so uh similar to Yo it'd probably
be unfair for me to be able to say I'll
be able to dedicate my time and myself
to one individual when I'm trying to
sort myself out first I think you're
selfish if you don't sort yourself out
first before allowing someone else to
get that close to you facts so having
sex if someone's not getting close
yeah exactly no I'm talking about is
that so that is not close for you that's
what I'm trying to say let me speak that
is not closed for you when you say for
somebody getting close I'm just trying
to find out because you might be having
sex with moon not getting close to them
sure
so I just want to know so you're having
and what's an entanglement
ask Jada Smith
explain entanglement an entanglement I
suppose you could call it caught in you
could call it dating like it's just cool
and you don't have sex when you call so
get it right right maybe in today's news
are changing up Cooling and dating if
you're gonna say caught in with sex say
call him all right I'll refresh say
dating with sex
cost you more money than dating with sex
what is it I've never heard of course
before sometimes
dating you smash court and you have to
stop
there is a big difference
are you dating with sex yeah we could
say that auntie and so where do you get
entangled because
I didn't hear about his entanglement he
was just like Yep this is what they want
I suppose you're getting it okay you get
into a particular scenario you think
potentially this could be someone who
you could be in a relationship with and
you couldn't end up being something
further with and as time goes on and you
get to know that individual and a bit
more that you begin to realize that
actually we haven't got as much in
common as we might think and therefore
it begins to fade a little bit and he's
like hang on a second maybe this is not
what I thought it was at the initial
beginning so therefore it begins to fade
right so do you prefer traditional women
to Modern women
that's a tough question mixture yeah or
if you deserve don't even interrupt yes
which one and why or do you know what
right when it comes to dating and when
it comes to entanglements
[Music]
um I suppose it's a different very
different modern view on it but when it
comes to actually someone who you want
to then actually invest time into and
begin taking more on a serious basis
you'd like to see someone who's got more
old-school morals about them and more
old school ways about them so I've got
them built into me
um without a shadow of a doubt but I
would only kill us I would only give
access to that to someone who I think is
actually worth that and it's actually
worth that time and worth that side of
me describe what you've got built in you
I don't say my old school ways and
morals what are they
[Laughter]
but I'll still like if I feel as though
someone's worth that sort of time and
investment then yeah absolutely like my
investment is in that and you do become
you know the old school gentleman ways
where you will take some of that
property you will take them out to
proper dates and proper restaurants and
get to know that individual on a far
more personal basis and open up to him a
little bit more but you only let that
side out to someone who you think is
potentially worth that and they've got
them sort of same morals and that about
them you know the types of girls that
aren't about that life and that are just
there to have a good time and that's
cool you understand that together and
you're like cool this is what it is and
that's it that's all it's gonna be but
when is someone that you feel as though
has further potential who could be a
potential partner of yourself and you
begin to allow access to different parts
of you that you don't give to everybody
else yeah so is that what you're looking
for potentially you do want to settle
down
um good question it's not a case of me
looking to want to settle down but if
someone you don't ever go look you don't
go looking for love you don't go looking
for life like looking no no that's not
what you want is that oh my God like
listen I met a lot of women in my life
and if someone was to suddenly show that
potential of someone that has those
old-school models and old school ways
about them and and
then yeah absolutely of course that
would that would that
there's an old school sign of um a woman
can never change a man but a man changed
changes for a woman and that's that's
100 true if you meet a woman who's got
their mores and and brings that side out
of you yeah that man will change it
doesn't matter what his past is about
that man will change for that woman to
be like you know what you are the person
and you are the woman who wants to make
me change that view and the way I've
been playing about for X Y and Z amount
of time yeah without a doubt so you do
either traditional 100 negotiations
oh wow go and sell yourself a good
question
um I think what you said maternal is 100
thing I can't wait to have a family I
can't wait to have children I've grown
up around children I've got seven nieces
I've been an uncle since I was seven
years old but three older brother's like
I can't wait to have my own children and
please God for mum after God's ears the
woman who I decided to have children
with is the woman I spend the rest of my
life with amen amen
actually like making sure that that
doesn't happen that you don't have any
children
oh you got me you got me you got me I
just gotta ask him what are you keeping
it covered
his pull-out game is stronger
yeah of course yeah we try not to muck
about too much in that business yeah we
tried to make sure no no no no no no no
no
Auntie Jenny no Auntie so from today on
right never we play something right
every this man doesn't keep it covered
don't sleep with him
if he hasn't got his well he's gone
don't jump down and sleep with him yeah
no maternal intelligent like she wants
to be driven ambitious like she needs to
be independent
um well I love hearing about women today
like they want to be independent want to
stand on their own two feet I don't want
to rely on a man a man should look after
a woman and keep her safe in that
contained up similar to what we're
talking about right like when she goes
out of a guy that's like oh I'll let my
girl go to the bar and buy a drink which
I mean if you want to buy a drink and
then I'll watch a guy try and chat her
up but I'll watch how she responds to
that yeah if he touches her in the wrong
position then I'm going to handle that
situation the way I need to right yeah
but you're there one day you're not
there I'll have people there if I need
uh
you're just going against everything
she just needs to like I like a girl's
got a backbone she needs to be able to
stand up for herself and be like no mate
like Marquis is XYZ like if I wanted to
call him down in a shot where's your man
you want me to call him and bring him
down here because I'll bring him down if
you want if you really want me to stand
on her own two feet you need to be
independent look after yourself has her
own job as her own money be I don't
interdependence yeah not not a girl who
needs to rely on him I want him to do
this no mate you you own your own money
you go to work driven yeah you want to
be promoted you want to own your own
business whatever it is you I don't care
what job you do take pride in what you
do and work for yourself not oh yeah he
does this to me he does that for me no
she needs to be standing on her own two
feet like babe I've made this decision I
want us to go here yeah I'll go there if
you I don't care like tell me where you
want to go let's go who's gonna the
relationship you or her I think I think
relationship is a partnership you're in
that together it's not a case of X Y and
Z don't get it wrong so if there's a
final decision to be made yeah it makes
it the pair of you know somebody has to
make a phone if it comes down to the
house and things like that it's just I
want that I'm like yeah you can have it
that's cool
when it comes to that sort of stuff I
think again I think you sit down if you
ain't got a relationship where you can
sit down together and have an adult
conversation about look this is the
reality this is XYZ like what do you
want to do about it if she kicks out
fast and doesn't know how to handle it
she's immature and doesn't have to look
after stuff so you want to lead it's not
about necessarily leading it's about
sitting down and having a discussion
between yourselves and thinking about
who's going to make the final decision
somebody has to why does it why you come
to an agreement thank you like if you
come to an agreement you say right this
is what I want this is what I want and
you can say fine and whatever okay I'm
saying that it's hard for two people to
lead of course it is so what's the
compromise babe you want that you want
that so I don't like I'm not gonna go
back against your idea and go against
you and go I'm [ __ ] having that and
that's it or you're having that and
that's it so what's the compromise we
either come to a compromise we don't
have it Mason the compromise is they
trust so if she makes a decision you you
trust in the decision yeah or if you
make it you see trust in it so one
person has to do it there's never a
thing where 50 it can't always be you
can't come to a middle ground see this
relationship is no no no somebody has
lie this is life in a family in life I
want to someone has to say okay if
someone's gonna be like I trust you in
your judgment I want to follow you sure
you cannot do this 50 you're going to be
arguing your whole life
I don't give it that I don't agree with
that I got a minute I got a minute he
didn't say that he said that she might
agree sometimes and he might say oh then
your way or someone has to leave but
what he's saying is that somebody so you
can't see it but it can be him sometimes
depending on what it is depending on
what it is depending on what the
situation is potentially maybe what
one's got more experience in what maybe
one's got does more of than the other
you go if I said to British food
together you said XYZ and Brit knows far
more about that another good but listen
babe I trust your judgment you I'll
Trust whatever you decide to go with I'm
with you but you realize that a real
leader does that anyway
everybody gets the wrong idea of course
of a man leading you're very naive if
you think you know everything a man who
leads will always then I think he's
insecure and then he'll make it if the
woman's better at money then a man who
leads will allow the woman because she's
answered with money a lot of people seem
to think that a man needs and the
woman's gonna do this no you just to
work together she might I'm not
necessarily great with numbers she might
be like I know girls who are accountants
yeah I mean I'm like babe you know far
more than I do I know X Y and Z from XYZ
experience but you're better than that I
am so listen I'm gonna trust your
judgments so this thing about I don't
know about everything
so listen to this here this thing this
whole thing of trying to not say someone
could be elite like we want to act like
if I call you a leader that diminishes
me it does not no no no so wait so even
the fact that you don't want to say I'm
gonna lead it's like by me saying that
my woman is no how about my woman
understands me and Trust what I'm gonna
go and do and she's like actually my guy
you go and do this and Lead this I might
handle something else but when it comes
to certain decisions you do that just
like if it comes to home decisions do
you think I'm gonna do anything I'm like
hell no you're gonna lead the whole
thing here's the money the budget I
don't want to know what it is just deal
with it because she's gonna lead in that
thing just not that color baby
do that sometimes fashion stuff yeah uh
I would never try and out for something
but she's gonna lead in that you know
what you're gonna look good in this
that's when I let you just run you want
a woman say Joe what I hate about in
society today people are too
multicolored about stuff yeah so they're
not like you say something like if I put
an outfit on if I put a top on my boys
are like this but we've been like that I
hope we've known each other our whole
life so we're very brutally honest but
most the time it's like people were
saying just to make others happy God
babe what do you think yeah that looks
nice you don't like an idiot so if I put
a top on or if I put a jack on I go babe
what'd you think I wanted to go I look
[ __ ] on you mate I just mean there's
nothing wrong in saying you know what
honest and Mason I don't think this
because you know what it is Mason when
you first started talking yeah and bitty
yo but we're gonna get back to you later
on but when you first started saying it
it was like you're bucking up against me
but when Auntie probes are you actually
were quite traditional you're very you
you're very traditional you've grown a
lot like you're actually very
traditional and you're on the customer
saying the things that I want to say but
something stops you from saying it and I
think you're trying to be too safe and
it's fine to say you know what actually
I don't don't want my girl to go to
certain places if I'm not there I
actually I do understand there's certain
dangers out there and if I tell you he's
coming around to our way yeah and if I
tell him not to go there I'm not
actually a wedding I'm not a massage
this I'm not aware but actually I love
my girl because all I can think about is
when my mom and dad used to get on to me
about oh who those friends are hanging
around with what where are you why
aren't you it's because they loves me
not because they oh of course they
wanted to stop me or stifling
what I was trying to what I was trying
to expand on on that right is that
I've been around I've been around the
world my mates I've seen a lot of [ __ ]
like I don't care if you're going to
Carney I don't care if you're going to
we are Festival I don't care if you're
going to fuse I don't care if you're
going to a boat at 338 I've been in the
most quiet pubs in the world and it's
erupted jump in and I've seen some
horrendous things so I don't care where
you're going I'll always have the back
ahead and my concern of
my girl is out there without me so I
need to know where that's what I wanted
to heal okay
so if I can't be there like I don't care
if my friend if she goes to Dubai I'll
make sure I know people in Dubai so if I
need to know where she is or what she's
up to she's in trouble
but just text me and just let me know
that something's going wrong and I'll
ring someone who knows someone who knows
someone that can help you out or if
you're in an area that I just cannot get
to I'll ring someone who knows someone
who knows someone that can get you out
of that situation so I'm never not
concerned about where she is or who
she's with I'm always got that [ __ ] on
the back of my brain but oh like that's
that's going to be no matter where she
goes but at the same time you can't stop
it from going places
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible